[Music]
really I was single mom for seven years
me too oh my gosh okay welcome back it's
extra cheerful in our studio today
because we are teaming up with our
season long Partners who I love so much
LG America's most reliable line of Home
Appliances we've been working with them
since the Inception of our show actually
we built our kitchen with their
appliances and I'm so proud that we are
still working with them and here to
share how to get your homes ready for
the holidays is none other than interior
design Maven Genevie Gord and
Genevie can we like start with a clean
scent and slate it is a clean slate and
we are kind of in a laundry room and
we're going to talk about holiday
decorating and the first thing before
you do anything is you got to wash it
kids it's not spring and fall cleaning
it's spring summer fall winter I agree
and fall is dirty it's allergy dust
crazy so wash cushion covers throws
comforters rugs a lot of these things
you don't think you can wash but you can
and here's what you're going to do
because it's the holiday I love a dryer
ball smell
it because what you're going to do is
add essential oils to your wool dryer
balls okay I've never done that and this
takes out all of that Gunk that's in
those drier sheets like because you
don't know what's in there right let
soak in a little bit I'm also doing a
lot cuz I overdo everything then let's
go Pisces I have a subtle bone in my
body thr it in we have a washable rug in
here what great that fabric looks very
familiar Genevie is that one of yours it
is you want it you it I know that print
so this dries and everything comes out
smelling like the holidays and you
haven't brought in a tree or wreath
anything yet I love that what's
beautiful about these guys LG wash toer
it's sleek and it's a smart design that
not only refreshes the look of your
laundry room and half the space but can
also refresh your home for the holiday
so put your guest room Linens in there
too this washer dryer is large enough to
even fit a king-size comforter it's like
a sports car in your laundry room it is
a car in your laundry room and by the
way imagine this in your home this is so
Chic and beautiful you know it's rare
that you say laundry is sexy but this is
pretty sexy I don't think it gets sexier
than favorite CH you can do the dishes
all day I will do laundry this
tablescaping is gorgeous okay so let's
talk about it cuz it's still a little
bit naked so you're like what are we
doing where's my red and green it's the
holiday right no we've done that so much
I love the chicest color in the spectrum
is black Scandinavians design with this
color all year long and it's great
contrast to White for everything let's
just say now when you're dealing with
heirlooms delicate Fabrics who can't
wash you go to the LG styler and this is
kind of like in between your dry
cleaning you have your own little dry
cleaning system in your house come
on so it steams all of those dry
cleaning items the heirlooms that you
want to bring out for the holidays and
those napkins that you never use cuz you
don't want to iron them you take those
out and they're perfectly steamed and
perfectly flat yes okay now that's crazy
so we laid out grandma's little doil now
I have a surprise for you this is the
centerpiece Bring It On in you guys we
have like 70
candles and it's the Tree of Life
24 in tall
tapers and you have this wall of life oh
my God I know we will show you a picture
of what it looks like
lit I mean this really is a wow piece
more is more with candles and you've
done it all with some really beautiful
workhorses that can stay in your house
all year it's a beautiful way to refresh
well we're going to give one lucky
studio audience member an LG was toer
and an LG Styler if they can answer a
trivia question correctly where is
Nancy hi Nancy hi Drew nice to meet youw
this is jevie hi behind the candles
here's our trivia question okay what was
Frosty the Snowman's nose made of was it
a a button B carrot C coal I I oh I want
to call a friend um most snowman are
carrots but I'm hoping a button button
but a button fcy I knew I KN we're going
home with both of these appliances the
LG wash toow and
the cleaner in your
own that is so amazing to learn more
about these products go to lg.com and we
will be right back congratulations
Nancy
[Music]